this is a production of cornell
university
the title of my talk is modeling street
trees on a statewide basis in new york
state but essentially what i'm doing is
it's a state of the state of street
trees in new york state it's a statewide
assessment of street trees
and just to define what a street tree is
it's a tree growing in the public right
of way
for the benefit of the community that's
how i'm defining it and public right of
way typically is
most often is a tree lawn like this
between the sidewalk and the street
now when you say for the benefit of the
public that isn't typically that wasn't
originally what street trees were about
they were basically for the amusement
and pleasure
of the noble classes uh
in paris that's where
but the american model is is far more
democratic
at least in theory and they're just you
know it's something you you see
everywhere it's a it's a fixture in
everyday life
although when we don't see them we go
gee uh what's wrong with this
neighborhood in lima as compared to this
and
uh we associate street trees
in many ways with with us the aesthetics
of the community the identity of the
community
but increasingly
what we're what we'd like to think about
is the benefits and ecosystem services
associated with street trees which is
something
i'm very concerned with not only in my
work here but with my work for
sustainable sites initiative
in austin texas
and so ecosystem services can include
storm water reduction air quality
improvement energy conservation and so
on
and they're basically
proportional to the amount of leaf
surface area
associated with the tree so here you can
see droplets of precipitation
intercepted by
by this leaf
now the forest service has gotten very
interested
in
conceptualizing thinking about large
large landscape scale
urban forestry and canopy cover and
they've done
invest a lot of time and money in in
canopy cover assessments for
at this landscape scale
and what they're
asked they ask two questions basically
how much tree canopy do i have
and
associate with that how many ecosystem
benefits do i have associated with that
and how much tree canopy could i have
how many planting spaces in a way are
available
which is good i mean this is a very
useful way to look at
what
exists
and what you could have but it doesn't
answer a fundamental question at a much
more discreet scale which is what tree
species should i plant
remote sensing hyper
hypo
spectral remote sensing is not all that
reliable in terms of identifying trees
species
so it also doesn't answer a larger
question
such as how many
ash trees are vulnerable to the emerald
ash borer as you know
the emerald ash borer is an invasive
pest species that is killing ash trees
and there's also the asian longhorn
beetle
which
is killing maple trees so these are
issues at a larger than local scale a
statewide scale that
are of concern to people like the new
york state department of environmental
conservation
and
the work i've done is really targeted
towards answering these types of
questions
now when i say scale
or level um you know we typically
collect data at
a very discreet scale and then we
aggregate it to the scale of the village
for instance write a report
but there are other
wider larger scales as well and you know
new york state is really what i'm
basically doing
is extrapolating from this scale of the
village or the municipality
to that of the state and as you can see
when you start extrapolating when you
start getting into a larger scale you
sort of lose a lot of your resolution
you lose some of the detail
associated with that data
it's a trade-off
so my goals
in in conducting this assessment and
basically i was i was working with the
dec
and this is some of these uh are
stipulated by them
but basically i wanted to identify the
prevalent the most common street tree
species in general in new york state i
wanted to estimate the the numbers
for those prevalent street tree species
in general
and i want to estimate the annual
benefits provided by street trees as
calculated by the
u.s forest service has a program called
a program called i tree
and some people love it some people
don't the dec asked me to do it using
that program so that's what i did but it
quantifies
in monetary terms uh ecosystem and other
benefits such as energy conservation
property
value and stormwater reduction
and to do all these three
goals i was i wanted to use methods
they were easily replicable by other
states because the issues that are faced
by new york state are faced by other
states as well
and the idea is that whatever is done
here could be could be exported to those
states potentially
how is this assessment different well i
should say that
these
the idea of a statewide assessment has
been has been contemplated elsewhere as
well
um
california has periodically sent
questionnaires out to urban foresters
and gotten feedback from them
washington state would like to do
something like this but they cut the
funding for it so they didn't do it
there are some some studies as well as
indiana and south dakota however what
they don't do is they don't
basically construct a statistically
valid model and that model is not
and their data isn't necessarily based
on street tree inventory data and they
don't identify incorporate geographical
geographical
differences into their analysis and they
certainly don't use gis in their
analysis and statistical estimates
now
essentially what i had to work with and
had to collect was data from
these municipalities i got data from 138
municipalities
i subdivided in new york city where you
have five boroughs in each rosa county
into into its
into its different boroughs so i had 142
data sets
the data that we collect that is
collected in street street tree
inventories is
species diameter
which is a proxy for the age of the tree
true diameter and also it's very
important is the planting look site type
whether it's in a tree lawn or a front
yard or a sidewalk pit or whether you
have utility wires
overhead
the other side of this equation is that
most communities in new york state don't
have street tree inventories
and another issue which is actually as
important is the fact that the data that
is collected is typically
all over the place it's not necessarily
standardized i mean i have maybe six or
seven different types of tree diameter
type data and the trick is to put it
together to aggregate it as as
as well as i can which isn't always
possible but uh and also not everybody
collects
tree genus a tree species they'll
collect genus but not species
so
it's a bit of a we call it a mess but
there's certainly some challenges
involved in the data
now
one thing that was hypothesized early on
and which
proved accurate was that
um
the data
the the the uh united states usda
planned hardened zones of which they're
actually five i aggregated
uh number three and number four because
in the adirondacks they're not that many
uh
populated communities but
that these zones were have the most
explanatory power of any variable i
found and you know just getting into a
discussion of
of of of these planned hardness zones is
is another topic unto itself and
supposedly they've been they're going to
be updated next year and if they do then
this will all have to be
redone which is fine but that's what i
went with the 1990 zones
and
in gis i aggregated my data into those
respective zones
and what
you'll see as i go through what i did is
that means for variables of interest
now these basically
so if i want to know these were the
constructs i used to sort of go to to
construct my analysis
and if i want to know the total number
of street trees per species or genus or
the total benefits for all street trees
i first have to know how many
or i have to estimate how many street
trees there are in new york state
which is a bit of a problem
um
but
to figure that out to ed to create an
estimate for that
i said well
the number of street trees is going to
be a function of street length and
populated places now what i mean by
populated places
populated places would be census places
such as villages and cities
but it's also census blocks with a
persons per square mile of greater than
500 people which is the census
threshold for suburban versus rural
and
i said well these are streets that we
can expect to to contain street trees
so then i had to figure out the length
of such streets
and just to give you an idea what we're
looking at is we're not looking for
street trees on interstates we're not
looking for them in driveways
we're looking for them in residential
areas we're looking for them in in
commercial areas such as those
and we can do this in gis we can
differentiate between
between types of streets
and for instance here we have the
outline for the city of syracuse
and we have in pink
well i would what i'm terming streets
expected to contain street trees as
opposed to interstates and driveways and
and roads going through shopping malls
and things like that which are mapped
but we don't want to include
now
it's also important to note that you
know
we have villages outside here we have
census blocks with greater than 500
people so those are also included in the
analysis we i did this for all of new
york state
and when you do that for all of new york
state
you basically find
so here we have
these are not all the streets in new
york state these are the streets that
i've differentiated in gis
and each street has a length associated
with it which you can sum the length of
and so i came up with a measure for all
this all of these streets expected to
contain street trees in new york state
of approximately 83 million meters
which is an estimate it's not exact
and then i aggregated that data
those streets to their respective plant
hardiness zones
so i have four zones with a sum of
street length in each zone
the reason this is important is because
the further south you go
let's say if you go from you you find an
increasing number of streets in
populated areas
so that's important because i used the
relative
length summed length of streets in new
york state by by zone to create weights
for for most of my subsequent measures
so in other words
when you get to westchester and new york
city and in suffolk and nassau counties
you have more street length associated
with populated places than for instance
you would um up in the north country
so
here's what here was my original
construct
and if i plug in my meters for new york
state
then i have to figure out what is my
number of street trees per unit street
length which is
the next thing i worked on
now as i said i have 142 data sets
and basically
did the same thing for all those and
basically here's the boundary of of a
village lima new york in livingston
county
and
because there's an inventory i know how
many street trees there are i know what
the length of the road is
in lima and i can calculate a measure
for street trees per meter or street
trees per mile
what's interesting is that
this
the mean the group mean for
this measure for four zones varies
so it's not it's statistically different
depending upon the zone
so for instance in zone seven
you have a greater number of street
trees per mile than you do
in lyman
which i believe is zone six
so statewide you weight the group mean i
come up with a weighted statewide mean
for this measure and it this weighted
statewide mean for this measure is
0.500 and it goes on and on and on
street trees per meter
so i take that measure
and i plug it back into my my little
construct here and i come up with
a a number an estimate of over four
million street trees in new york state
now there's also a standard error of the
weighted statewide mean associated with
this so i can create a 90 percent
confidence interval
for how many trees or likely street
trees are likely to be throughout new
york state
so that that's
i've gotten this far
and so i'll okay back to figuring out
the mean percentage of street trees or
species
that's what i have to figure out next
now for each
inventory where i can do this this is
what a typical inventory looks like we
have the number of trees we have the
percentage of a particular genus in this
case
maple is
heavily represented which is not unusual
in new york state
basically i take each inventory
percentage i create a mean inventory
percentage by zone
and then i take my weights that you saw
before and i wait
i weight that to create a weighted
statewide percentage
for each generating species
and if we look at
these are the five most prevalent street
tree genera in new york state
and
it's interesting that they seem in most
cases they vary
geographically we can see for instance
that acer maple
is much more
is less prevalent down uh in zone seven
which is westchester suffolk nassau
county in new york city
conversely we see
more
prevalent plantings of
quercus which is oak plain tree
papyrus
whereas gleditsia is pretty evenly
distributed
similar
street tree species
you know this is kind of interesting how
norway maple spikes way up here but
and it's also interesting to note that
the foremost four of the five most
prevalent species happen to be maple
but again we can see you know sort of
different geographic difference
in prevalence
so
i go through all the data i construct
these i come up with these mean
statewide means for
for
each species i have confidence intervals
uh 90 confidence intervals they do the
same thing for for for genera i do it
for species
in this case acer platinoids nori maple
is the most prevalent
street tree species in new york state
and
i frequently not frequently but i often
get asked how many ash trees are in new
york state because communities
the state wants to get an idea of how
many ash trees are potentially
vulnerable to the emerald ash borer
and if we take the number of estimated
number of street trees and the statewide
weighted mean
we can estimate that there's there are
142
000
ash trees
street trees in new york state
you know there's a fairly big range here
is as to what the number could be and
uh you know i have a feeling that if i
had more data that number would go down
but it is what it is
there's a lot of variability in the data
and it's sort of reflected in that range
so
what i did for ash i did for the most
prevalent
genera and so
i estimated that there were about 1.8
million maples in new york state
i can do the same thing for species and
i estimated there are approximately
864
000 norway maples in new york state
and that's that's useful information to
know if you have to budget for
planning statewide for ash removal for
instance
i was also asked to look at these the
annual street tree benefits provided
on a statewide basis and okay
this number we know how many there's an
estimate for how many street trees there
are i need to know the mean benefits per
street trade now
as it happens
going back to lima
we can calculate this in this with using
this software and it's just an estimate
but
the estimate was that each street tree
provides 132 dollars and 68 cents per
year
uh per treat
now what's interesting is that this
number does not vary statewide which is
interesting because
the density of plantings varies
statewide but this number does not vary
statewide so i didn't have to create a
weighted statewide mean for this at all
which is nice
and when you plug that in
you get kicks out a number of statewide
annual benefits provided by street trees
of
approximately 556 million dollars which
is not insignificant um
and you know there's a 90 confidence
interval as well
um
additionally because i went through a
lot of data and did a lot of summary
statistics
we see other things going on in the
street tree population
and one of the things has to do with
species diversity and the fact that
species diversity
these are two different species
diversity indices but they both indicate
that the further south we go the more
species diversity there is
and
we also find that
species diversity is greater for cities
and for villages and
what that seems to be about is that
if cities and cities with greater
financial resources typically are able
to hire a city or a city forester
and the forester
is
knowledgeable enough to know that
species diversity is an important
consideration
and and therefore plants accordingly and
we see this reflected here
what we also find is that
it's not sufficient statewide
and there's a 20 rule for instance that
no one single street tree genus should
exceed 20 percent of the population
and as we can see here the great
majority
of the poppy of the municipalities for
which i have data
exceed the 20 percent rule i mean some
of these have percentages of maple
between 70 and 80 percent which is
extraordinarily high
so bottom line too many maples
and if we look at this graph of
tree diameter what we find is that well
we need we would like to have more we
would like to have in the zero to six
inch range we'd like to have more street
trees in this range here
to compensate for the mortality of both
young and old trees
and we don't we have we have
the fact that this
no this bars right here suggests
strongly that we don't have there's not
been enough
planting of new trees recently
which
is going to have a long-term effect on
the number of trees on the streets
um i also looked at sort of
compared the
species composition for trees in the
zero to six inch range to all the
composition in all trees and what you
basically find
is that
this part's sort of good because you
have you basically
is basically suggesting that as a
percentage of the population fewer
maples are being planted
but what you also see is that we're
having large numbers large increases in
in
pears and in
crab apples things like that which is
going to lead to a structural change
in the street tree population over time
and that's sort of borne out by this
graph which says that
you know larger
and medium-sized trees
are being planted less often than
smaller sized trees
what's very interesting is that this has
nothing this has
power companies such as nice and
national grid have made a big effort
recently in recent years
to suggest
and rightly so that smaller sized trees
should be planted under
single and triple phase utility wires
and that's good that should be done
however
if you look at whether utility wires are
present or not what you see is that
irrespective
of utility wires that the that more
there is a trend toward planting
uh more smaller sized trees and there's
no graph to illustrate it here but it's
true as well
with respect to planting volume if you
look at
planting sites such as
somebody's front lawn
or yard where there is no essentially no
restriction on planting volume you'll
see that increasingly
smaller sized trees are being planted
there as well
now
i hypothesized and found that
the most explanatory power
for the data i had had to do with plant
hardiness and my plan in the 1990
usda plant hardiness zones but that
isn't to say that there aren't other
correlations with street tree data there
are
medium household income
annual precipitation and type in
municipality whether it's a city a
village
or or a census designated place does
have
a correlation but what i found was that
number one
the plant hardness zone had by far the
most explanatory value and that
these variables were were
multi-collinear
with
with this one so i couldn't really use
it just tossed it out now that doesn't
mean that if we went to another state
for instance we went to washington state
it could be that annual precipitation
would be
more significant but in new york state
it's not
so uh
i was asked by the dec to take my
initial findings and then go out and do
some additional inventories
and see how those the data from those
inventories
compared to my initial findings and i
did five villages uh
shortsville
and and lima are in in zone six but yeah
and i have one but i had one at least
one from each zone and i did
uh intensive you know
street tree inventories on foot for each
of these
uh five
uh they're all villages
what i found is that you know is the
data exactly the same no but basically
you see
very similar trends
between
how many
how many trees per unit stream length
are planted i mean as you go further
south you get more trees
planted per per unit street length
and
fewer maples as we get down to when i
went to great neck plaza which is nassau
county
fewer maples were planted
which is what i would
expect similarly
more
oaks were planted higher percentage of
oaks
norway maples you know you see that
spike up here and then goes down we get
to further south
and same with london plane tree
now you know they're not exactly the
same but i think they're reflective of
the overall trends
if you look at the tree tri diameter
profiles for the five villages i went to
very similar
you know not enough trees in this
particular zero to six inch category
so
i concluded that yeah you know i was on
the right track that what i did seems to
be fairly accurate um
and my test inventory statistics don't
completely agree with my zone class
level statistics but
they seem to reflect the overall trend
that i found in the data
however
what's important to know and it can't be
emphasized enough is these greninic
plaza in kensington are
contiguous you can put one foot in great
neck plaza and one foot in kensington
but their pop their street tree
populations are quite different
and uh they're somewhat different in
in their planting types for instance all
the trees in kensington are planted not
in the tree lawn but in the front lawn
here which is part of the right of way
so
there is a lot of variability
from one municipality to the next
irrespective of geographic difference
it's just the nature of the beast
so conclusions from all this analysis
one clue conclusion is that we need more
species diversity we need more diversity
of both the species species and genus
level for street trees you know it's
like the maple that ate
or all the other species here
too many maples
why is that important well this was hope
plaza
it was american elm and the american
elmo died because of dutch elm disease
and had to be replanted
this is worcester mass
i believe these are all norway maples
the asian longhorn beetle really likes
maples they had an infestation of
asian longhorn beetle they had to cut
all the trees down that's what it looks
like now if you had more species
diversity there would be less
even if you had the asian lore orbital
hopefully your street wouldn't be
reduced to that
we need more planting of trees to at
least maintain population the population
at the current level now it's very easy
to stip to sort of call for 500 000 new
trees that's a lot of money i
i don't think new york state is going to
be funding 500 000
or 600 000 new street trees because you
have to think about mortality of your of
your plantings
it's probably not going to happen
anytime soon but that's something that
we need
because
larger
sized
trees
provide more ecosystem benefits
we
emphasize
where plantings
volume is adequate and you don't have
overhead wires to plant larger growing
and medium-sized growing trees
it's not really being done
at the moment there's a trend towards
planting smaller sized trees for
whatever reason
and if we look at this data that was
collected by ohio state where they
compared the growth of uh
cretagus
and gallaudet there's a there's a great
there's a tremendous
difference in the amount of uh
and the size of the tree and the leaf
surface provided by the tree and if you
sort of plug this into
this this uh forest service program
basically
the cortegas the uh the honey locust the
ditzy is providing eight times roughly
eight times the amount of benefits
provided by the cortegas it's a it's a
big difference
you know eight times the amount of
stormwater mitigation provided by the
gleditsia as opposed to the protagonist
so what's going on is that we're
basically
we're we
we're programming a reduction
in ecosystem benefits provided by street
trees street trees are roughly
10 to 20 percent of
of the urban forests you know it's not
an insignificant component
and the forest service has spent a lot
of time and a lot of energy trying to
get out the message that street tree
benefits are important
and the question that needs to be asked
is is this message being heard and if
not
how can the message be
retooled so it is heard
and lastly
i was asked to
use methods that could be replicated by
other states
what i did this assessment depends on
having enough street tree inventory data
that's broadly distributed throughout
the state
which
is not so easy
it's a bit it's an important issue it's
hard to say new york state has a lot of
data
and also uh you know here at cornell
through the swap program we've generated
a lot of data
so it's hard to say whether other states
have enough data that could be used to
rep to replicate what was done here
the other thing is probably not as as
obvious is that you need
data about streets because
we need to have
we need to use gis to go through the
street data to do what was done here
and presumably we can do that
through departments of transportation in
those states
and lastly the other thing to consider
is that you know in new york state plant
hardiness zone was
the best predictor val
variable but not as i mentioned before
it's not necessarily true may not
necessarily be true in other states
and to try it in another state and see
what happens
so
i would like to acknowledge uh my
committee nina basic peter troubridge
and joe francis they've been extremely
helpful and i appreciate their their
wisdom throughout the years and it's
great to have advisors who are older
than i am
which is hard
i'd like to thank the united the new
york state department environmental
conservation providing funding
uh i'd also like to thank the
municipalities and and
urban forestry companies and
individuals who had the data and who
provided it to me
i would be remiss if i didn't thank the
cornell
student weekend arborist team
who
not only
collected a lot of the data during the
fall but helped me
over a summer or two collecting data as
well
and i'd like to thank the departments of
horticulture and landscape architecture
for putting up for putting up with me
for all these years
and lastly i'd like to thank
my wife diana and my kids who have also
put up with me for a lot of years as
well
so thank you i'll be
happy to answer any questions
it was that clear huh yeah
i wonder if you
did you look at things on a finer scale
or was it too difficult and thinking of
some examples could be like street use
type you could have divided it into
residential
in each of the zones versus commercial
versus intensive residential or
something i definitely did look at that
um
and
that is exactly the problem
the problem is taking data at that scale
and extrapolating upwards partly because
not everybody collects data at that
scale and the data that you're talking
about has to be geo-referenced meaning
it has to each tree has to have an x and
y coordinate
so you have to know exactly where it is
not everybody collects that data not
everybody collects street address
so so and then it has to be correlated
with measures such as land use and stuff
like that
which
may be accurate may not be accurate
that's another scale issue so i think
that is the way to go
but at this
in this analysis at this level at this
time
um
you know i my uh i did i did do what
you're talking about but
i wasn't comfortable
drawing too many conclusions from what i
actually
uh analyzed i have a reduced amount of
data at the level that you're talking
about
and so looking at both geographic uh
variability
and differences in land use and other
variables it you know i was sort of
running out of room
in terms of the data didn't we uh
our swat inventories had
would you reference but
most inventories don't take gps a lot of
them yeah most
it's hard they do but
it's very uneven and um
you kind of i'm kind of limited you know
that's that's exactly the right question
that's a great question and something i
struggle with all the time and and
it's just uh
not everybody collects the same data
in the same way at the same level
and it creates a lot of challenges so
you know it's frustrating because
when you extrapolate to the statewide
level you're sort of not answering a lot
of questions but that's those are the
only questions those are the questions i
i was i felt comfortable answering
oh we have a question in geneva sure
yes
um yeah i have this alan like so our
question in a comment uh on the i tree
uh model of the forest service develop
is that
does that take into account the
difference in ecosystem services that
you get with an isolated tree versus
similar tree in a forest
because an isolated tree will intercept
lateral light and
you get quite different numbers if
if it's isolated versus within a within
a stand the short answer is yes
yeah those programs the i tree programs
that i use are specifically
uh targeted on to street trees they have
another program that looks at forest
stands
trees
but the
forest service also does it on a span
basis
right
i think we have one more also uh just a
comment we uh
for vineyards we've worked with uh
art digotano and the climate center and
he's generated a much more high
resolution
uh temperature climatology
at the three by three
mile scale
and that's available uh
to
you know potentially be a lot more uh
high resolution than those no i
understand i understand that and uh
oregon state has a prism model and they
have 30-year normals and all that stuff
and i i started off using that
and
it actually
um
actually
i don't think it works as well for what
i was doing for whatever reason
um
it's also not as widely available it's
not as easy to get it's not as easy to
use
and so you know uh ult that's how i
started off working with with
temperature hardness and i wound up
going back to the or went up going to
the to the
to the usda zones as as cumbersome and
as clumsy and as
out of date as they may be i'd be very
interested to see the updated zones
and see how that affects this type of
analysis
you know i think prism isn't very useful
because they give you averages
this this one we can
i can tell you what percentage of the
winters fell below specific temperatures
at a five by five kilometer great scale
for the whole state so
you may want to look into that i can
send you more information okay thank you
take me a little more i've got a comment
right this martin goblin
i'm on the city of geneva's changing
committee
and i'd like to comment on the
statement you made about large species
no longer being
involved now i guess we cut
cut our own arm off and that
we do have more
access to urban
foresters and so on that advise us and
we're no longer human planting a large
species anywhere under a wire
so right away
we're doing away half of the street
trees on any one street because they're
on one side of the street
so
we're going to be stuck with large trees
on one side
and small medium trees on the other side
which
i suppose it's diverse but it's not a
very pleasing look
well one thing you we might want to
think about is
on the side of the street with the wires
not planting in the tree lawn
and maybe we plant in the front yard or
lawn of the
of the parcel
and uh
then you could
potentially plant a larger sized tree
and not have the
displeasing aesthetic which is what
you're
talking about
right
well there is
uh it's an educational thing
to the to the homeowner to allow a tree
they tend to not fare well when a person
doesn't want them in their lawn
but uh if we educate people and get a
setback agreement uh that's actually
signed so that the city takes care of
those trees we have had a few that have
come forward and one in a larger
i just think it's something that we
could consider moving forward that
the traditional model of planting trees
and tree lawns along the street maybe we
could rethink that a little bit that's
all
thanks yep
yes ken do the utility companies
exaggerate the problem of trees
do utility companies exaggerate the
problem of trees under
i wires have uh
i just heard an nvr this morning that
there's a call to
not plant trees near wires
and all in connecticut after people
still don't have power there
after the week of the snowstorm but uh
i mean there are different types of
wires i think what fred talked about is
single and triple phase which are the
tall ones and there's table of thick
ones those are cable
and power you know fiber optics and
they're not the ones that we're
concerned about as much as the high ones
a single and triple phase that
is a fire hazard because they're not
well insulated and then there's also
potential for
stopping power if the trees come down
i think it's a valid thing
to plant trees that mature at a height
of 30 feet
that's why those wires are above 30 feet
versus uh you know having to plant
really small trees but
but when you don't have the high between
triple phase in a single phase you can
plant victory that's back to typica when
we do do plant big trees if you just
have cable and fiber optics which are
those thick wires we'll plant right
through this
is there
you have a level of saturation with how
many trees are
feasible to even have per
mile kilometer of street and then also
can you correlate your tree diameter
size
with how old the street is i'm just
wondering you say we don't have big or
small trees to take the place of the
older trees but
we have a point of saturation with some
of the oldest streets they already have
on uh
two densest saturation trees to allow
the small trees even
special niche
well you probably know more about this
than i do but um
yeah you can't plant
of course you can't plant a tree every
five feet but
you can definitely plan for a
newer tree you see it all the time where
you have great big old sugar maples
let's say
and and younger trees getting planted
between them
on the theory that on the on the plant
looking ahead they're gonna or will
remove the older
probably possibly diseased structurally
deficient sugar maple and allow let the
new the younger tree to get established
and then remove the tree
yeah you you there are and and how
how uh what how on center what the
distance on center i mean that's that's
that's kind of a question of being
discussed right now i know in syracuse
is what is the proper distance between
tree plantings you know is it better to
have a greater distance or a smaller
distance
but yeah i mean that's
kind of what the forest service has been
interested you can't just plant it it's
great to say yeah we'll plant a million
trees in new york city but where
you know um i'm not sure if i answered
your question but
did i well i was wondering you know if
there's a correlation with the smaller
trees just because maybe
new rule construction has been
there's that correlation there that's
the whole reason why we're having this
the younger the smaller trees is
something they've seen in california
they've seen it in many different states
i didn't make that up it's been and it's
not unique to new york city
new york state um
everywhere uh i you know you can
speculate i mean to some extent it's
it's a function of uh
uh
departments of public works that usually
typically maintain and
and plant the trees consider those
smaller trees to be easier to maintain
and so they're more inclined to plant
them
and that may be true in the short term
that's not necessarily necessarily true
in the long term they're looking at
reduced maintenance costs which is a big
concern of theirs
but you know there's possibly also in it
i i thought about maybe there's just how
we think of the street
has changed i mean we're no longer such
a pedestrian-oriented society we're kind
of a drive-through society
and maybe that's part of it we don't
look for the same thing from trees that
we use now that we used to but it's it's
not on you it's not unique to new york
state is it this trend of smaller
smaller
sized plantings
yes tom
fred did you come up with a number for
the
the number of trees that
could be planted yeah
no okay no
absolutely not we have those for our
40 swat cities that we've done that's a
real scale issue yeah but we don't have
it for the other
places and on a statewide basis that's
okay well thanks very much
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu